we got our boy Justin from SD Justin
from San Diego hello there hello Brendan
this is Justin from San Diego and I have
a debate club for you guys today
beautiful tea I grew up listening to
classic rock and I still do listen to
classic rock quite a bit and I want to
know what do you guys like better
The Rolling Stones or the Beatles it's
the age-old question I personally have
to go with the Rolling Stones but I want
to know what you guys think
stones gang beetle buzz let's hear it
it's a good question it is it's kind of
like what do you prefer the whole
[ __ ] band the boys with the [ __ ]
you're cut remember they all have the
[ __ ] the monkeys they all look the
same was that the monkeys Beatles did oh
yeah
the same thing to John Legend John
Lennon right dark beetle that Darth the
darkest beetle bro
Oh so back is rolling stones or the
center delete singer Mick Jagger right
yeah that dudes bodied yeah he looks
like yeah he looks like a Steven Tyler
if you like hung his head out of a
window for a long time boys moving car
moving it har no these guys are legend
goes that hits Rolling Stones handsome
yes give me give me one of their bang
look at that guy right there suddenly
you know is that all I got shred the old
Harry Styles brother dudes a legend yeah
you're right
I'm more of a Rolling Stones man yeah
what was the other thing
now the Beatles you knew more of them
like I can't tell you who else is in the
Rolling Stones man it's Mick Jagger and
then after that dude it's all marbles
yeah
yeah the Beatles is high right I have no
clue for the Beatles who it's John
Legend
goddamnit John Lennon who else Paul
McCartney I'm off a prank oh sorry can
beat Ringo just on the keyboard wouldn't
he yeah he kind of he kind of looks like
a muppet days kind of like but as far as
like tunes dude dude hold on we can't
not name all four Beatles bro or we're
gonna [ __ ] lose it do you have for
lacan Lennon Paul McCartney Ringo Starr
who's that fourth who's you guy that got
murdered by his wife that's you think
George but who's the fourth Beatle Chris
Benoit no it's a wrestler Benny I know
he killed his wife think to themselves
yes oh you know it was speaking your
Tennessee Titans hat go Titans dude
Steve McNair Steve in there good call
the fourth Beatle me I've been recruit
know everybody every time somebody
shoots somebody or as an abortion they
blame it on Rae Carruth you so sick of
that I can't I still can't before I know
you can't bro you know I've known you
for years man whatever it is you can't
um the fourth Beatle yeah dude you think
I'm a freaking the delinquents yeah I do
really even after I walk off that jacket
with this fresh ass net throw his [ __ ]
it has a chance though I want you and
Peter Dinklage to have a head-butting
contest hold on the fourth Beatle is I
know it it's Ringo it's Paul it's Daniel
no John John Paul Ringo and right there
John Paul Ringo
Allen uh it's a man talk about Todd
Snider no it's not Todd think about the
letters the outfit go through that it's
art with an A no B no C no no Harry no
what's this the last thing your clothes
Harry's the last thing your clothes with
that Barry it's not very not what is it
no truth you said truth is a black guy
George George George what Harrison
George Harrison you idiot ever heard of
yeah well I've never heard of that man
George you've never heard of George
George Harris was still alive no I've
heard of him a thousand times you do bro
McCartney won't [ __ ] leave us alone
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]